thank you
welcome to this joint audit and
standards committee i am counselor david
muller
and i am chairing the meeting today may
i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
but if you are attempt attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded
i now like to introduce the various
officers
so the officers attending the meeting
today are emily ewell
the monitoring officer john snell the
corporate manager for internal audit
risk and data protection jan robinson
is she here today corporate manager for
democratic services and sue palmer who
is the senior finance business partner
capital and treasury so
i'd no like to move to the agenda please
there will be an amendment to the agenda
and i have agreed that item 12
the annual audit letter will be heard
after item
seven so um one
apologies chair um if i could just
interrupt i do believe that we've got um
catherine steele with us as well this
morning apologies
yeah unfortunately catherine wasn't
mentioned on the list so apologies
i can see that you're there so apologies
for that
um so we're moving to the agenda
apologies for absence and substitutions
please
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor fraser
thank you very much item number two
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary
interest by members are there any to
declare
no okay thank you so item
three this is jack 20
um 01 and
this is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of july
2020 and it's on page 5 to 16 of your
papers
are there any inaccuracies to those
minutes councillor lindsay please
thank you chair yeah um my name's been
spelt incorrectly
in the i think in those minutes and the
ones for
um the next lot of minutes i think in
both of them
okay ui instead of i i it should be a y
sorry but we'll let it go
thank you council lindsay a council of
the crawl
thank you chair there are a couple of
extra words in um
uh 28.24 as an extra
as and in 29.5
there's an extra that take those out of
the
the the sentences make sense it's just
okay format sometimes it's easy to do
yeah no that's absolutely fine thank you
councilman mccraw uh are there any sort
of other um counters wish to raise any
issues with accuracy on those minutes
okay thank you very much so moving on to
um the next part is are there could i
have a proposal
and a second to please
pose in a second uh mike naraz happy to
propose
thank you counter norris and counseling
crawl
happy to second thank you very much i
will now ask the governor's office to
conduct the electronic votes
please thank you chair um councillors
could you please open the vote in the
modern.gov app by clicking the plus sign
in the top right hand of the agenda
and selecting attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote
we feel quite strongly that the
we we needed to have those minutes um
provisional minutes a very long time ago
those two meetings were a long time ago
six um five months whatever it is now
um there were things you know looking
through
follow-ups and so on and i really needed
that
reminder um of what we've been
discussing back in july and august so
i know whether perhaps the committee
services can make a note
about that um and that you and the
co-chair can um agree to circulate the
minutes
in a timely way once they're available a
couple of weeks after the meeting please
thank thank you for that counselor
matterson i'm sure we'll try our best to
actually to do that if we possibly can
thank you
well i'm pleased to say that that vote
has been carried
so i'd now like to move on to item
number four
which is jack 20 stroke 2 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 11th
of august 2020 which are on pages 17 to
22.
again this is for accuracy only um
councillor huron
yes um good morning dave this is the
meeting that i actually chaired
um they're fine apart from
4011 which is on page 19.
um there's a paragraph there that
doesn't make a whole load of sense i do
remember it at the time
it's the last bit it says the assistant
director for sustainable communities
for further him to provide a reply i
think it should be clarification
for him um just for the sake of good
order it needs
maybe um councillor matheson would like
to comment but it just needs a bit of
tidying up for the record yeah sorry
which which one was that i've got a
couple of them highlighted um
it's 40 11 john i'm just looking at
i mean it's seven um
okay yeah that would be i've come up to
it now yes that's right
yeah it's just yeah it's bad but dodgy
english isn't it oh my name spelt wrong
there as well
okay well perhaps we can correct those
then um
we just wanted to um
yeah for him really for him to provide a
reply
yeah or you just just change further him
to
to uh for him further
yeah i'm sure we can do those case of
lindsay did you have a question on the
accuracy please
just again to say my name's been spelt
wrong throughout okay
yeah i'm sure we can correct those um
council lindsay and the other
issues raised by kent saharan and
council matters and so
so thank you for that do we have any
further questions on the accuracy of the
minutes
in that case could i have a proposer and
a second to please
uh chairman i'm quite prepared to um
propose that they be passed as a true
record
thank you thank you have a second to
please
i will thank you councillor matthewson
um
therefore i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please
thank you chair again councillors if you
could
go to the modern.gov app
and access the vote through the plus
sign
the vote will be in progress blue
thank you very much um mandy um
so the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and i will be and will be
signed at the next practical
opportunity moving on to agenda item
number five
and that's to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
do we have any competitions mandy at all
please none received
thank you very much item number six
questions by the public
none received thank you and item number
seven
questions by councillors again none
received
okay thank you very much i would now
like to move on to
um item number 12 which is jack
20 stroke 7 the annual audit letter 2018
19 a report from ernst young the
external auditors
and could i ask um suresh patel pleased
to
discuss this paper thank you suresh
thank you chair and good morning to
members of the committee
um most of you will be familiar with the
annual audit
but for those of you who aren't this
summarizes basically the work
that we uh completed on your 2018 19
accounts if you recall
that audit was rather protracted due to
a combination of uh
our own kind of resourcing issues and
then the the pandemic
in terms of uh when that hit in march
but so the letter really shouldn't have
anything in there that you have not
heard before because we reported to you
at the end of july that we had completed
that audit we signed
those accounts off the end of july um
the only thing
that is in there that was uh subject to
conclusion at the time was
the final fees which are on page 20 and
21
and they were agreed with catherine have
subsequently been agreed with psaa
um so that's really all i wanted to say
on the
audit letter chair uh just to say that
for 1920s that
audit is currently in progress and we
will report in completion of that audit
at the next
committee meeting in january take any
questions
thank you very much do we have any
questions for suresh please
okay saharan you've got your your hand
up or is that a legacy hand what's up
and you're muted
yes it is a legacy hand i didn't cancel
it german apologies
just while i've got the floor i wondered
if suresh would like to comment on page
20 the fees
um um there's 40
000 for housing revenue benefit which is
it seems to be as much as the um the
bill for the council um
um audit fees is is that normal i
presume being quite new to this suresh
um
i was a bit surprised that it was um so
i wonder if you could just explain the
work
that um incurred that bill please yeah
yeah so that's that's a that's a good
question um so
you engage us separately to certify your
claim
uh for housing benefits subsidy with the
dwp so there's a separate
engagement letter that we have for that
work and
it's a bit of an odd piece of work for
those of you who are not familiar with
it because
in essence um it's driven by
testing across your claim for subsidy
and depending on if we identify errors
in initial testing it then drives the
need for further work
so the fee itself is based on a base fee
of assuming no errors but then every
time we identify an error the dwp
requires us to carry out further testing
which then adds to the fee that gets
charged so the total fee that we had for
18 19 the 40 000 is
is because we identified a number of
errors which required further testing
uh and subsequent amendment to your
subsidy claim
so you're right it does look a bit odd
the fact that that's as much as the
audit fee but it's two totally separate
pieces of work
okay and the errors are the errors
by claimants by the council or by the
government whose errors were they just
just so i can set apart i'm around so
there would be errors by the council in
terms of how it's administered
a certain claim often is to do with
changes in income of an individual that
i
haven't caught up in terms of when those
changes actually
were made or uh it can be sometimes
interpretation of some of the guidance
that you do with the issues so
i can't remember off top my head all the
detail on that but we issue a detailed
letter
to the council which which outlines all
those areas and i get agreed
with catherine and her colleagues okay
fine then thank you sarah that may be
something we need to work on but um
thank you for the explanation and thank
you chair thank you coach howard
councillor lindsey please
thank you chair yeah um so still you
look at um
uh sifko in this um
uh in in your audio when you look at
properties
so we look at cifco in as much as
clearly that is a a subsidiary of yours
which gets consolidated into your group
accounts
so the extent of our work is a
combination of relying upon the auditor
of sifko itself and then looking at your
consolidation
arrangements for 1920 we are looking at
the valuation
of the assets that sifkal holds because
that clearly that has an impact in the
consolidation
so but 1819 i don't think we identified
the need to look at the valuation of
civic properties at that stage
good because um obviously where we
took a write down on the value of the
assets and
in sift coast so um and i know i think i
don't know whether you're talking
about this afterwards but i saw there
was a kind of
inspection that the some kind of
national regulatory body did
um of all um auditors and local
authorities they
were sort of and i think they
you we got a letter from you saying that
you you came up
sort of clean as it were um but um
one of the things they highlighted was
um
that there wasn't enough attention paid
by orders to the um
when there's a revaluation of council
properties
whether they are actually you know how
realistic those revaluations were
so um i think that that would be quite
important to have
for future thank you thank you lindsay
uh councillor caston please
thank you very much mr chairman um
suresh with this
um in the investec
fund in this um i believe they've now
changed the name of that fund to um
91 plc um so the
the name of the investec fund changed in
march
if i'm right if that's the same one um i
wondered if that could be
that name could be just for transparency
that name could be added to
um 2.5.8
so that people can um
tell that that's that's renamed that
fund we're not on that paper councillor
casten are we
um i did i did get a
we're on the letter james oh sorry sorry
i've um
yeah sorry i'm jumping the gun apologies
yeah no problem
thank you thank you casey casa uh
councillor matheson please
thank you yes the um i was just
wondering
about the um that this uh hra government
um
claim for the user housing uh benefit
isn't it
um do we actually do we actually bring
that letter
to this committee also
i don't think as a matter of course you
do there's nothing to stop you from
doing so
it's a letter that we write to the dwp
reports in results of our work as i say
gets agreed with the council before it
gets
issued to the dwp in previous years
as part of the audit commission
arrangements we used to report
in detail on claims that we've certified
because there was more than benefits at
the time but
since since the psa arrangements
there's no longer a requirement to
provide that kind of report
but there's nothing to stop you
receiving that detailed
qualification letter if that's what the
committee
wants yeah yeah if if the
extent of errors is generating at the
fee levels
um it sounds if it's something that we
ought to
be looking at i wonder whether catherine
steele's got a view about that
catherine do you have any comment
comments on that please
yes thank you chair yeah i'm more than
happy to circulate
that um detailed report from from ey to
the members of the committee that's no
problem
yeah no i'm happy with that and i'm
happy with that uh comment uh caitlyn
matheson
and agree with that comment thank you um
counselor because you did have your hand
up did you you've taken it down again
did you did you have a classmate
no done you're okay okay does anybody
else have any other questions
for suresh
no if not do any members wish to debate
the um paper 12 item 12
further
uh council of accrual i just say that it
seems to be a complete
bill of a complete bill of health um
and this is something of a formality
because we did examine this at our last
meeting which was only a matter of three
or four months ago so
yeah i'd propose the uh letter b is it
be to be noted
it's just to be noted we don't need to
vote so that's fine we don't need to
have a proposal
so that's fine i'm more than happy with
that yeah
thank you very much yes i too would like
to pass on my thanks to suresh and his
team
and again it's fantastic to see that mid
suffolk and weber have got an
unqualified external audience report so
thank you very much for all the officers
and seres and his team for all your hard
work and ensuring that's the case
thank you very much everyone on that one
i know like to move back
to the actual agenda so the agenda item
number eight
which is the uh jack 20 stroke three
half year report on treasury management
and i now invite sue palmer to senior
finance business partner capital and
treasury
to present the report please sue over to
you
thank you chair this is
the joint treasury management report
covering the position for the first six
months of the financial year
thousand and twenty twenty one it
provides details of the performance
the effects of decisions taking durian
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities
including the regulatory framework the
economic conditions
interest rates and liquidity risk
in a relatively short period since the
onset of the covert 19 pandemic in march
and the ensuing enforced lockdown in
many jurisdictions
the global economic fallout has been
sharp and large
market reaction was extreme with large
falls in equities corporate bond markets
and to some extent
real estate echoing lockdown induced
paralysis
and the uncharted challenges for
governments businesses
and individuals the unemployment rate
increased to
4.1 with the expected peak when the
furlough scheme was due to finish at the
end of october
of between 8 and 9 but this is now
likely to be revised following the
extension of the scheme to the 31st of
march 2021.
interest rates remained at a record low
of 0.1
and the headline rate of consumer price
inflation fell to 0.2
year on year so more specifically for
our two councils
uh banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits
each council has reduced overall debt
baba by
6.5 million and mid suffolk by 17
million
both councils made repayments on
long-term pwlb
loans baba report repaid
short-term local authority loans and
mid-suffolk replaced medium to
longer-term local authority loans with
short-term loans each council lent the
further 1.6 million to cifco
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
uh the council's investment activities
including average returns
can be found at appendix c of the report
investment by both councils in funding
circle
has further reduced as unallocated funds
have been reclaimed and existing loans
repaid
for baber this was 48 000 of the two
hundred and fourteen thousand previously
invested
and for mid suffolk it was fifty three
thousand of the two hundred and fifteen
thousand
uh leaving balances on the 30th of
september of 166 000 for baber
and 162 000 for mid suffolk
uh both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
and the investment activity undertaken
for the year was done so in priority
order of security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
so uh councillors if you have any
questions we will be
happy to answer them thank you sue
do members have any questions for sue um
on this particular paper um counselor
mclaren please
thank you so um somebody that's really
quite ignorant
about the investment uh procedure
can i ask you some questions about the
procedure for making investments rather
than the investments themselves
is that okay yes certainly yes um
who makes who actually in the council
makes the decision
as to which investments are going to be
made
how does that occur in a process
yes we have um certain
officers who are uh delegated to be able
to make these investments so they
uh contact people like brokers
uh the shorter term investments tend to
be through brokers
um and then the longer term investments
we tend to sort of
discuss things with our treasury
advisors are in close
okay we have uh quite a lot of
discussions with and
um you know obviously they uh we take uh
advice from them okay and then
the is it a team a group decision
the final outcome of that
um i think it it depends um
sort of what the investments are that
say that
things like the the pooled funds the
longer term
investments and uh
[Music]
that they tend to be a a group decision
uh or approved by
uh catherine melissa um
and the i'll say the short-term sort of
day-to-day activities where we might
need to put money in like overnight or
for a week or for a month they tend
they've been sort of delegated to
offices so
officers make those sort of shorter term
decisions if you like and so
in terms of as we're on the scrutiny
committee
um uh what is in place
for some external group to
ratify those decisions that are made
you know somebody else in the council
i'm not talking about external
is that is there somebody with checks
and balances on those decisions that
have been made around the investments
chair could i perhaps come in here yes
absolutely catherine thank you
thank you chair um we have the approved
treasury management strategy
for each financial year and that comes
into
council in february each year as part of
the the budget setting papers that's an
additional paper
so that sets where we're going to invest
the types of institutions that we're
going to invest in and the limits that
are placed on on the various places we
invest
and then i as the section 151 actually
have delegated authority
to undertake um all the investments in
accordance with that
that strategy that is approved each year
so um ultimate ultimately if i feel like
it's me
that has the final decision on that but
some of it as sue was saying is
delegated to officers on a day-to-day
basis
and one final question i'm sorry i don't
think it goes to sue or catherine
um is there any sort of
thought about ethical investments
as such from a council point of view
yeah it's something that we are looking
at
we've subscribed to another service that
our
treasury management advisors have bought
on stream this year
so it's something that we're looking at
but obviously we don't want to
take any money out of our current
investments if that means we would lose
money at this point in time
so we are looking at things so we're in
a better position when we have a
a chance to actually reinvest some of
the money
because it's interesting that ethical
investments this year
since covert have actually done very
well uh so that's the quote
the reason i raised the question yeah so
thank you sue
thank you catherine thank you chairman
thank you
mclaren uh i know take questions from
councillor caston
then councilman mccraw then councillor
matheson so councillor caston please
thank you very much mr chairman i think
i'm on the right paper now i'm sorry i
just
i did massive delay on my um documents
and they
weren't coming up and i flicked for and
i thought i was going to miss the
opportunity to ask the question but um
i'll ask it now so the um
i think the um end of this for
talking about the um the funds side of
this
we've got a um we've got a schroeder and
a um
and the um investec
funds um it's a really unfortunate time
to um
to um look at how these funds are doing
because
um it's the end of september isn't there
and
they were just about the lowest they
were and i think um
uk equity incomes had an uplift of 15
in november uh alone so i think the um
the next look at those funds will be a
lot more pleasing than them
than this one because obviously with
covert we had that
huge drop in march and they've they've
slowly come up but
most of that most of that's been in
november so it's not it's not clearly
where they are
they've changed since this report was
done the um
the investec funds are they
now 91 plc have they changed the name on
them
uh yeah yes they have yes and i noted
your comment earlier
so we will um in future we'll change the
name of the
the fund yes it's it's called 91.
yeah yeah that's it because i just think
if people want to try and
follow um what's happening with them
yeah that would be difficult
but um i know that when they started off
they were investec
and and they finished as 91 plc but
it might it may have confused them
people slightly
but um yeah no i just um yeah i think um
okay those those funds do look bad from
this one
this particular one but i think um they
haven't
performed any differently to any other
funds
during this crisis they've um they've
been in line
um with how the market's gone and
and they're coming back up and i think
they will still continue to be
good investments solid investments and
arlington close have um obviously helped
with that um
advice on that and i think i think
they're good
they they're they're good investments
but i'm yeah i just
i i feel it's a bit unfair the to take
this snapshot right now
is um yeah thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you uh
counselor mccraw please
thank you chair um i'm also looking i
think
as councillor casten was at appendix c
and
and i note actually i i would
characterize page remember
uh that's page number 43 john thank you
or around pages 4243 appendix c
um yeah i note and i'm just going to do
a general overview of these funds
because that seems to be something that
we're focusing on
but in paragraph 1.14
i note actually that i had a character i
mean again i could be
characterizing this differently from
councillor casten but
the average return of 4.8
in the climate we've just been through
in this first
this probably the worst possible six
months imaginable in terms of
treasury management the return of 4.8
doesn't seem to me to be all that bad
and when i look at the tables further on
ccla um yes a reduced figure from say
4.3 down to 3.9 but we're still
in the same ballpark now these are uh
that's quite a significant amount that's
five million
uh schroeder two million
uh invested and we're still achieving
four point five percent
the ubs 2.5 and um
is performance of a gallon 2 million of
about 4.42 that's actually increased
the rate of return um i looked at these
figures and compared them with
the previous year obviously we're only
dealing with six months here
um but given the climate would i be fair
to say that
actually that's rather an impressive
performance uh investec
um yeah the average rate of return
um was 6.18
if i'm reading that correctly that's the
balance
2.5.8 no that's up to 6.18
that's a significant increase um funding
circle i know we're reducing my
correcting
analyzing it this way we're reducing our
investment in funding circle
um and quite small amounts are invested
in that now
uh and that's where the rate of return
has dropped to below three percent
the one i suppose that is going to
achieve some focus and i would like to
focus on this one
particularly is sifka
uh the trading card sorry um
council do you actually have a question
on this i do actually i'm just right
this is where the question
lies is i'm looking at the overall i
think the funds do have
i'm just trying is this the way i'm kept
reading this is actually
a rather better performance than might
have been expected is that a fair
statement and that is a question but
when i look at cifco i see that we have
interest receivable and interest payable
on paragraph 3.8 on page 47.
um and the figures shown
indicate interest receivable is that
interest actually received
or is it receivable that's
an important distinction because
obviously if we still have a
deficit or rather we haven't received
all that money yet you could argue that
it has not been received
but the interest payable um we have a
cumulative net interest
on the trading companies in sithco
which seems to me to be surprisingly
good we are more than covering the cost
of servicing the debt is that right
that the despite some of the fears
expressed previously
and in a very poor trading period cifico
is actually paying its way in terms of
servicing its own debt
regardless of capital value am i correct
there
would you like me to come in there chair
yes yes please catherine yes
um yeah in terms of uh your first point
councillor mccor about your summary of
the
investments and you know what you said
the position was looking like then yes
you are correct
they are continuing to provide
reasonable income returns back to the
two councils
um i think councillor casten was
possibly referring to the current book
value if you like of those investments
and there has been a decrease in the
book
value but we're holding those
investments for the the medium to long
term so obviously we can ride out this
current position and the values will go
will go up again in terms of
cifco yes um cifco is still
if you like say covering its own debt so
they are so far this year they have been
able to pay
to the councils what's been owed on the
loans
so yes that that debt is being recovered
obviously that's something that we're
continuing to
to monitor with cifco and that's not in
that's in actual returns without without
with with possibility of more money
owing where arrangements have been made
but it is actually not only covering its
debt it's actually providing an income
yes and that is that was the whole
purpose of
you know that they did present provide a
return back to the councils
so that the interest that is charged on
the loans to cifco
is more than we pay in the debt
that we're servicing very interesting
thank you
thank you catholic occasional matheson
then council lindsay after councillor
matthison please
thank you yeah i think the the the
answer to
council mcgraw to some extent is is that
the the problem
the problem of the interest being
received
is within sifko's accounts rather than
in the council's accounts at the moment
um
what i wanted to wanted
to ask about and say really is that
the um i'm obliged to council mclaren
for for raising the ethical investment
question which of course has
been a fairly um recurring theme
um from me over the years um
and it's interesting what she says i
haven't particularly noted that the
ethical investments are doing well at
the moment i did however
um get a promise from councillor
whitehead on thursday
at the full council meeting that the
the arling close report that catherine
mentioned will be brought to
this committee um next time so if we
could pop that onto the agenda
um arlington got a new report regarding
um it wasn't described as ethical
investment was it catherine it's
something similar to that anyway um
so if we could um put that on the agenda
for next time please
thank you thank you coachella matheson
um councillor lindsay and then
councillor huron
for council lindsay please thanks chair
yeah it was a in a similar vein to
councillor matheson um dude i mean
i also on the county i sit on the
pension committee and
um we've i see that we've um
got some investments with ubs um ubs
and our i think from a previous question
that i
got the answer to our um
equity investments in uh treasury uh
about eight percent of them are in
fossil fuels
which is quite a high proportion given
the
falls that the risk that we're we're
taking with
with what is essentially a dead end
industry
so um uh i think if we could
what i wondered is we've moved the
pension committee we've moved all our
passive investments
we're about to move most of them into
into ubs climate aware fund
um which um tracks them it just it
filters out a lot of the
the nasties as it were um so i don't
i don't know if is there any
um issue with ireland close um
you know they seem to be the provider of
financial advice to
to local authorities and treasury
management but are they
the provider of esg advice do they know
their stuff
do you think or are the better advisors
actually if we're looking at ethical
um investments in the treasury manual
thanks can i ask catherine to to answer
that please thank you
um i i think the the treasury management
advisors are learning about this at the
you know with everyone else and i know
that they are aware it's an
important strand moving forward i
believe they do actually bring in other
expertise as they need it so they may
not have everything in-house
so their their new service i think they
have called on
on other expertise to come in and talk
to councils about
about what's possible so yes i think you
know they are
they are upskilling themselves should i
say in this particular area
thank you very much kathleen um
councillor hurun please
yes thank you chair um councillor mcgraw
wiped out most of my um questions to
start on the financial matters
which i'm very grateful the only thing i
would comment is that um
i wish i could get 4.8 out of the tsb
um yeah you know absolutely brilliant
but
just a few other smaller things on 4.8
um sue mentions
call accounts um i wonder if you can
quickly explain what they are i think
it's sort of like short term isn't it so
but um as as my if my memory serves me
correctly could
could you just confirm that yes uh
yes counselor yes there they are just
very short term maybe overnight or
something like that so
it the immediate you know funds
immediately available if we need to call
upon them i think that's where the kind
of
phrases come from and i think i've read
elsewhere in your port that
actually rather than earning us money
sometimes we pay sort of a tenth of one
percent to
put money in there is that correct now
it's gone sort of in reverse hasn't it
um certainly recently um
the government's debt management
facility that's
the very short-term um investment in
there has gone to a negative
and uh yes so they're positive for sort
of longer rate
longer-term uh investments but they're
immediate
uh say call or overnight or like one to
two weeks uh aren't currently negative
yes right is there any chance of doing
anything about that
or is is that just where we are
i think it's uh an example of the
current economic climate
and um i mean obviously we
look for the best rates that we can so
um
we're still trying to invest in uh
positive you know
uh investment uh houses where there
are positive rates of return
yes thank you sir i do understand that
it's horrible to read a negative figure
when we're actually investing money
isn't it
um but as you say it's where we are just
quickly
sir further on your report dependency
page 39
you mentioned the money we were given by
government
and there is a surplus i just
but it doesn't say what's happened to
that surplus um
did it go back to government the money
we couldn't hand out
or do we still have it
do you want me to perhaps
yes yeah i think the
majority of the money that we had in
terms of business grants was paid out i
can't remember the percentage now
the top of my head because we've had
further funds since to administer on
behalf of businesses
but i'm pretty sure something like over
90 i think was actually paid out
i don't believe the government has asked
for the balance to be repaid
yet but of the 20-odd million that we
received that's a small proportion that
we're now just holding
until the government asks for it back
and is that certain to happen did it go
back
or unfortunately yes i think it will
oh damn
it would have been so good and my final
point just to back um
comments made by councillor matheson and
mclaren about the
um well i think um mary mclaren called
it ethical i would call it
environmental you know um i think we
should start
as catherine has said naturally moving
um to better investments
um investments that look better for us
um
fossil fuels is obviously um a bit of a
no-no so
i welcome the gradual move to that thank
you chair that's um
that's me done on this paper thank you
keith lahard uh counselor mccrawl then
keisler caston then councillor matheson
please
thank you chair uh still an appendix c
on page 48 i'm looking at paragraphs 4.3
and 4.4
um 4.3 describes a reduced income for
both councils
4.4 describes reduced borrowing costs
and reduced investment income
and i'm trying to square those figures
um
what's the net effect i mean if we've
got reduced borrowing costs of 420 k for
baba and 885 k for mid suffolk uh
does that counteract the loss of
investment income
um and is the is the reduced
figure 82 and 83 for mid suffolk and
baber
or babe mid is that the net effect
to the two councils
again do you want me to try and try and
come here
two paragraphs and relate them to each
other yeah um
i think they they still stand on their
own so then
they're not trying to um either of them
aren't trying to bring everything
together
so in terms of paragraph 4.3
this is where we've budgeted for income
from those investments that we've just
been talking about like the schroders
the ccla
the the invest tech so that's against
budget not
that's against absolutely yeah and
in terms of paragraph 4.4 there are
two two effects so baba particularly has
benefited the first half of the year in
a reduction in borrowing costs again
against
budget of the 420 000 pounds
because we budgeted to move some debt to
long term
but because of the current low interest
rates we've stayed at short term
so again that's against budget and
you've got a contra against that is the
investment income from
cifco because cifco wasn't able to get
as far
invested as they'd hoped to in the first
six months
of the year in terms of buying
properties so we've seen a against
budget again
a reduction in the income but for baber
if you take all of those three together
you are still
have a benefit if you like in the first
six months of this year
so the net effects uh should be
calculated for each council but those
are only against
a budgeted figure that's right yes thank
you
that's what i needed to know yeah uh
thank you councilman
thank you catherine for that uh
councillor caston please
thank you very much yeah i'd just like
to go back to these um investments just
for some clarity um
maybe i'm reading it wrong but um
the um schroder maximizer fund
page number uh page number
page 44 well um
2.5.4
um on on the table on the um
appendix c yes
give everyone a chance just to find that
um yeah so um
i um by my calculations
schroeder income maximizer fund invested
on the
10th of february 2017 um
would have sat at about
16 growth um before the crash
before the covid sorry um and it would
be
um it would be negative now
um i think the um please tell me if i'm
reading it wrong the um
that would be less than the original
investment
um i know other councillors have said
that's a good return on income
um just just to make this clear can we
um discuss we don't have to talk about
where
things are now but um um
surely by my calculations we wouldn't we
wouldn't have made those um
amounts of growth
um oh sue did you want to come in
catherine uh yes thank you chair yes the
there's there's two sides to the
investment there's the
sort of a amount of principle if you
like that you've invested so
for schroeder for example we've invested
two million
in cash terms which at the 30th of
september is
now valued at 1.2 million
um where in addition to that we're
looking
for income from uh like like interest if
you like
uh in their in the funds um investments
which
is then um equivalent to the interest
received
interest receivable so the like for
example baby's
average rate of return of 4.68 that's
the amount of interest that we've
received
so you've got two sides to the
investment you've got the
the value of the actual investment that
we've made
plus the um income that we're receiving
through interest or dividends if you
like um
paid through the fund yeah no okay thank
you that explains it really well i think
um
it's um it's not done on the book cost
it's not
um it's done on the um the
the in income from the fund yeah now
that's that's fair enough that
makes sense where you got that figure
from but um yeah just to just to be
clear with my
previous statement that the book cost
has come down
it is worth less i'm not this doesn't
worry me i don't think this is i think
this is a
due to the times i think we've got we've
got a good
fund there and um the covert situation
has hit
everything um and i think that will come
back but yeah i just wanted to be clear
on my point
that um yeah book book cost has come
down but um yeah that's um
average rate of return isn't the book
cost
thank you thank you casey casa uh
councillor matthewson please
thank you excuse me um yeah just
a few final points on this really um i
i think the um you know the the point
about the
the levels of income and um and
catherine started to talk about that a
bit more just just now
um you know we're getting what 4.8 looks
looks good because a lot of it is is
long-term investment which was taken out
when interest rates
um were even more generous than 4.8
so um that's the and i was just
wondering is it then
implicit that the the big shift that i
think sue talked about at the beginning
of her piece um the big the big
repayment of of borrowings
um was replaced by short
short term borrowing at much lower rates
of interest and that that's
what we're doing at the moment because
it seems like the right thing to do
um but the uh the other um the other
little points finally then was the um
i think council lindsay
was asking about um other other advice
etc so
maybe when we get the arling close um
report um back incidentally for
councillor haran i think that the
um the usual
um phrase i think counselor lindsay
abbreviated it to esg
its environmental social and governance
um criteria that are
are kind of grouped together in order to
produce
what would be called an ethical
investment
um you know that those three factors are
all
sort of better than average let's say uh
at least
um so maybe if there are other advisors
perhaps we could
we could kind of just review that next
time along with the ireland close report
to make sure their advice is is as as
good as is available
but the final sort of question really
was
to just to reassure myself that there
was a
um there were reports about i think it
was thorough
local authority which had gone round the
country borrowing
money from dozens and dozens of other
local authorities
um in order to run a property investment
scheme similar to sifko
and um this all looked to be in
considerable jeopardy
and i think as far as i can see on the
graph
that we're not we're not actually
lending to
other local authorities in any
significant way
could we confirm that
catherine could you confirm that please
um i might look to sue who's closer to
the day-to-day but i don't believe
we're lending much to other local
authorities
is that true sir that is true that is
correct yes we're not
lending to other local authorities yeah
i think
the the graph seemed to say that
i just wanted to to make sure really um
that we're not i've lost it again now
but yeah there's a nice pie chart on
pace no that's not 36 that's that
borrowing again
anyway yeah so the answers the answers
we we're not seeing in any significant
way so
there's definitely no exposure risk
there thank you
thank you counselor matt uh counselor
haron you still have your hand up is
that a legacy hand or did you want to
ask another question
thank you chair no it's a negative and
it must be an old hand i don't know why
it's still there it's not showing on my
screen
okay thank you um counselor lindsay do
you have another question please
i'm afraid well just perhaps just to add
to the
other add to the confusion but
councillor casten
um has helped so i'm grateful to him for
um
um talking about you know where we are
with those funds and uh
but it appears to me that if if we are
we not simply
this is an income maximiser fund so
but i mean any fool can give us a high
interest rate
if they're eating into the capital value
of the fund
is that what's happening
no i believe i believe this is just the
current market position
as you know um equities and fund values
they go up and down with the economy
um and there's councillor cast and said
it was unfortunate that the report of
this date is as at the end of september
it is a snapshot in time
and you know the investments will go up
and down as you can see
from the comparative figures that we've
got so i think it's unfortunate that
this was the end of september um and i
would hope
but of course we've got brexit coming up
at the end of december that things might
start to improve as we bring you the end
of this financial year position and sort
of into next year
good thank you thank you council lindsay
if there are no more questions
i will now open up this item for debate
um do any members wish to debate this
item further
counselor crawl please
really just to note that um
catherine referred to it in her last
answer
that uh markets do go up and down
dramatically
we've just seen the dow go up to 30 000
which we are told is a sacred number
well no number is sacred it's just a
number
and these are all um matters that do
change dramatically because they're
actually anticipating a future
and we are primarily investing under the
treasury management for
income purposes the amounts concerned in
fact
relatively at five million in here and
two million there
are not significant so i'm not concerned
about valuations to a great extent
obviously we would hope long term that
they will rise again
but in the meantime their purpose is to
provide income and they appear to be
doing that
i'd have to say that the treasury
management team
be quite entitled to give themselves and
feel quite satisfied with their work
over the last
six months given the depths
um and the fears that everybody had in
march
april and longwoods uh to have come out
with achievement
like this um in over the last six months
and to have minimized the
the loss of income and of course in fact
we've gained in some cases in terms of
our net
borrowing cost i think they could be uh
yeah well satisfied to give themselves a
pat on the back and i would suggest that
the committee
do so as well the recommendations are
clearly demonstrated
we're within our operational boundaries
we're compliant
uh our activity is in is in completed
accordance with the approved treasury
management strategy
so i'd like to propose both motion 3.1
and 3.2 as being very very
uh sensible things to do
thank you council of the court and yes i
would like to echo what you said a big
thank you to the treasury management
team
um for the sterling work they've
actually done during this this current
pandemic
um councilman you've got your hand
raised again were you looking to see yes
i just i just wanted to to say that that
um yes our treasury strategy is
um is careful and cautious and um
we there has been extreme volatility
um and it stood up to that reasonably
well so far
and we hope it will and i'd like to
second the
that we note um the um
paper thank you very much casey matheson
council mccraw did you wish to come back
you got your hand up still
no i think everything has needs to be
said has been said
okay well thank you very much for the
debate and the questions on this item
we have a proposal and we have a
seconder i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
on recommendations 3.1
and 3.2 which are on page 23 of your
papers
thank you please thank you thank you
mandy thank you chair
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov app by clicking
on the plus sign
in the top right of the agenda and
selecting
attendance and voting in the voting tab
the vote for this agenda item will show
in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote
can i just say mandy mine hasn't turned
blue or just sorry
i hadn't clicked the button i have now
sorry okay thank you
thank you chair that's unanimously four
thank you very much
indeed i'd now like to move on to item
nine on the agenda which is jack
20 stroke 4 the internal audit plan for
2021
and the progress report and could i ask
the corporate manager for internal audit
jon snell to present his pay for police
thank you john thank you chair
and good morning councillors counsellors
the the purpose of this report is in
effect twofold firstly
to provide members with details of the
audit plan this year
and how it's been developed and revised
in the wake of kobit 19 and secondly the
work
undertaken to date against the revised
plan which also includes
details of other corporate activities
which are supported by the work of the
team
initially the plan was developed and
constructed to ensure it delivers
against the public
sector internal audit standards and it
covers
themes like governance processes ethics
information technology risk management
and fraud management
the planning process recognizes that
both councils are striving to improve
services
and use innovative approaches in
delivering services against the backdrop
of reducing funds
and have therefore directed resources
using a risk-based approach to to
maximize the effectiveness
of internal control the construction of
the audit plan has been developed to
support
both the annual government statement
which comes to to this committee as
you're aware
and also the council's six key strategic
themes uh in developing the plan
um we assess the sort of following areas
so we look at the risk profile
so we give consideration to the
strategic and operational risk registers
we look at corporate importance and how
that fits into
the joint strategic plan and the
outcomes that sit beneath that
we look at management concerns have
there been any significant projects
changes in systems or processes
we look at financial materiality so
that's looking at the budget the volume
of transactions the value of assets
and we also look at the control
assurance aspect so that's around the
audit knowledge levels of assurance
provided against
the three lines of defense
and then sadly covert 19 arrived in
march
which resulted in the councils reviewing
its priorities to ensure that the
critical services
were maintained and appropriate
resourced the approach taken by
management was to
evaluate the key governance processes
that enable frontline services
to operate within a framework of control
looking at our business continuity
arrangements and look at the resilience
generally across
both councils excuse me
um so in undertaking um this assessment
a number of questions were directed at
service managers to establish the extent
of the impact code 19 has had on their
service area
now that assessment helped internal
audit determine the key risks
key risk areas and direct their
resources accordingly
and as a result of the reviews and the
discussions with service managers
um internal audit were able to draw
a number of conclusions i mean firstly
there have not had to be significant
variations to controls
and the control framework has
transferred well
to aspects such as remote working
now this would indicate that the council
has a robust framework that can adopt
at a time of crisis and i think we'll
all agree that
we've done some sterling work both for
members and also officers to make sure
those critical services
uh have been maintained changes to
working practices undoubtedly have
occurred but these have not reduced
control generally and in some instances
i'd have to say that
has improved in terms of efficiency
processes with automation often
replacing previous perhaps manual
physical activity
where changes have been enforced staff
have maintained a clear understanding of
the basis of control
and i think in most instances created
solutions which have been maintained
and also maintain the integrity of the
processes
as the head of order i can in principle
provide reasonable assurance that the
general government's controls across
councils have not been overly weakened
because of the changes made to adjust to
to cover 19.
there are areas that have been
identified where the council is
potentially at a greater risk
as a result of the pandemic and these
have been included
in the revised audit plan which you have
before you
and include grants to businesses
excuse me significant internal audit
resource
has been signed since april 2020 to
support the processes in respect of
coveted 19
related grants to businesses by
one contributing to discussions
regarding the setting up of systems to
check
and pay grant applications assisting
finance colleagues with preparing
records enabling payments to be made
performing ongoing checks to reduce
fraud and advise on actions necessary
where fraud is suspected
or ineligible claims have been made
providing assurance and carrying out
initial investigations where necessary
over payments that have already been
made
we're currently looking obviously itself
isolating payments funds
and again internal audit helping support
this
by acting as a critical friend in
ensuring that the council's approach
to this scheme is compliant with
government guidelines and subject to
robust due diligence and financial
controls
another area of concern uh again across
the country
is around cyber security i'm sure you've
all read a number of
issues that both the public and private
sector are facing through
cyber security so we're undertaking a
review of the cyber security
arrangements
the security controls which include
remote access
and cloud storage and also to consider
network security and infrastructure
management and as a result we're working
closely with our colleagues
at suffolk county council in terms of
financial governance
we looked at to ensure that the councils
are maintaining
robust financial governance in relation
to the new cov19 arrangements
and this includes evaluating the
adequacy of key controls around how the
councils collect
manage monitor and control financial
information
we've also been looking at budget
control that's a process of managing
centralized budgets communication and
challenge of budgets spread across the
services
control of one activity uh dependent on
another
the second part of the report now sort
of concentrates on the progress of work
against the revised plan
so during the period um significant as
i've mentioned
significant time has been spent by the
audit team on supporting the
councils uh in response to the impacts
of kobe 19
firstly through the tactical management
team and also through the business cell
which i mentioned
uh is dealing with the business grant
payments
it should be noted that it's always been
the case that
the 2020 21 internal audit plan
needed to be fluid and flexible enough
to respond to changing risks
and priorities and particularly
obviously in light of code 19.
this fluid nature of the internal work
plan is particularly demonstrated in our
added value
work which has always been concerned
with using internal audit resources
where most impact can be achieved i mean
it
quickly became clear around the
beginning of the financial year that an
important added value
area for the internal audit team was to
focus on those covet 19 related
grants which i've mentioned to
businesses and therefore a significant
audit time has been spent in this area
as a result and this is not unexpected
less order insurance has been carried
out within the period
than would normally be the case and
therefore some rebalancing of the
internal audit work is planned for the
remaining year
which is necessary to work towards an
annual internal
opinion being issued at the year end to
support the 2020-21 annual government
statement
from the work that's been undertaken and
completed which is detailed in appendix
b you'll see that one audit received
a limited assurance ordered opinion this
relates to
the review of the housing compliance
against statutory
and regulatory health and safety checks
the audit highlighted a lack of general
governance and oversight
of the council's compliance checks and
also there was some evidence
that was lacking in some areas
management have acted very positively to
this i'm very pleased to report and
have complying uh developing a dashboard
which will assist addressing these
issues supported by a compliance
action plan which is being developed
because it's received
limited assurance at this stage then a
follow-up of the recommendations will be
taken in
later undertaken sorry later in the year
in addition to the work carried out
internal audit lead
on the production of the ags as i said
from 1920 which was presented to this
committee in july
as the head of audit i also attend the
statutory offices working group to
provide appropriate
professional determinational governance
matters as they arise
i'm also one of two deputy monitoring
officers
that support emily emily ewell as the
monitoring officer
with specific duty to ensure that the
councils their officers and elected
councillors
maintain the highest standards of
conduct and all they do
in terms of risk internal audit
continues to maintain and
facilitate development of the council's
significant risk register with councils
and senior management
and as a living document internally will
regularly review the content with
management and report annually to this
committee
again the last report being in august
internal also provides support to
corporate managers in their development
with their operational risk registers
which forms part of their service plans
in terms of probity uh full details of
the anti-fraud and corruption work
undertaken during the year
again was reported separately to this
committee back in july
entitled managing the risk of fraud and
corruption
there are no other additional related
audit issues that i need to raise with
you
at the moment so i'm happy to take any
questions that you may have at this
stage
thank you thank you john um do we have
any questions for
john snell please
counselor madison please
thank you so little delay there um
yeah yes the i think something that
that's
a concern i know that we're still
relying on
um external um support
to carry out internal audit functions
um i wonder whether we're we're still
trying to
to reduce or eliminate that and and i
think the particular
i think that the particular exposure if
you like
that kovid has brought there is that the
you know with with external
um external help um
it was presumably less able or not able
to be
transferred into the um into the
the various groups that were formed
specifically to do the
the um the responses to code
so i wondered i wondered about that
and you know what the current staffing
level is
um for internal audit within within our
own
um payroll and um
and just a suggestion i wondered whether
if we're not making progress with
recruitment
whether it would be an appropriate place
to get an apprentice
yeah excuse me happy to answer that and
thank you councillor matheson
with the external support um the company
that we have
is is tier um we had um
hope that obviously at the beginning of
the year this was prior to covid that
they were going to be starting on the
first of april
obviously then um kobut sadly has had a
tremendous impact
across the country and as a result the
contract
with tier got put back until july now i
have to actually say they have reacted
extremely well in taking up the mantle
so um the contract was for 150
days they are going to honor those 150
days
um so we're trying to cram in a lot of
work you'll have to also appreciate that
they have a number of other
clients as well but i have been given
assurances by their director of audit
that they were honor obviously the 150
days
that we have provided them so that's
really pleasing
um in terms of i just wanted to sort of
bring out in terms of external
provider they have a range
of expertise that we wouldn't
necessarily be able to call upon
from the in-house team so they have for
example a dedicated intelligence group
so they look across the country what's
going on
at various authorities they are a party
to all the changes in terms of
legislative changes
and they are actually feeding that that
knowledge back to
us as a client so that's really
important i think we can benefit the cat
both councils can benefit from that
knowledge
um that they have and they're happy to
share without any additional costs
so that can only benefit the councils
in terms of the in-house team there is
just
myself and another full-time
audit auditor lead auditor we lost
um which sounds very careless um
two auditors one as i said it was a lead
for audit one was a lead for risk
um and we're trying to sort of bridge
that gap
um hence why when i tried to advertise
for
the lead auditor position um that was a
part-time post
unfortunately there weren't any takers
and i did actually speak to my
counterpart in suffolk
wondering whether that was possible that
somebody who has
would like to increase their hours would
like to to do some work for for us but
there were no takers unfortunately
and hence why i did a paper to senior
management regarding the option
appraisals of
what was open to us in terms of the
audit service provision
and in terms of the good fit and the
support it was
agreed at this point in time that we
would actually
look for an external provider um there
we are still looking
at other options and another option
maybe a shared service later
perhaps sometime in the future as well
but obviously
that's in its infancy your point about
apprentice
i think is a very very valid one um
i've discussed this with with my line
manager emily yours here today
excuse me and what i would like to see
perhaps again moving forward is taking
on an apprenticeship
uh an apprentice um and having the
opportunity
then to to mentor that individual um so
there's again there's some resilience
within the in-house team
uh as we move forward and i think that
would be very important
thank you very much john yeah thank you
in turn if i could have a
you know follow up to that the um
i think the resilience is is the word
and um
that's why i was particularly concerned
that that we
we didn't we didn't have at the
beginning of covid
um as many you did not have as many
people
as we we would have all liked um
able to switch into these um quite
difficult
challenging even um extra activities
and you know i i certainly wasn't aware
until today that we're now
um involved in the isolation
self-isolation payments as well as the
business grants
and um there's certainly been publicity
about the
the business grant um schemes being
exploited fraudulently etc etc so i
i think the not having the ins
you know the um the external
support um wasn't wasn't able to come
into the covid response when we needed
it
so it you know it is we are vulnerable
in not having those people
um so i think you know that we need to
try every which way
to you know to get to get
sufficient um in-house resource really
um i think that's my my concern
is really yeah if i could come back
chair um
mr councillor mathews um actually t
are actually are now undertaking some of
that covid work
so we've looked at the financial
governance arrangements um
and that's in draft and looking at the
draft it's very pleasing
the report that they've produced and
it's also a testament to
um catherine and melissa and her team um
that there's only been one sort of
recommendation which is a sort of a low
risk so
um tier have been involved um the reason
why they couldn't get involved obviously
april that they had their own problems
where they were having to furlough staff
as well
because some of their other clients
weren't able to to take on their
services but
as i said i i was really pleased that
they could come on board from the first
of july so we haven't lost
too much time at all and as i said
speaking to my counterparts um not just
only in suffolk but in the middle and
audit group which i'm a member of
audit teams uh have lost a number of
staff that have been redeployed
it's unprecedented times as you can
appreciate so
you go where there's the greatest need
and hence why my auditor lily simulink
was doing and is doing a lot of work
around the business grants
um because obviously the rhetoric is to
get those um that need it most
so there is a rebalancing which i think
i mentioned in my presentation
um you know we're just trying to
plug the gaps at the moment but i'm
confident at the year end that i'll be
able to provide a
an end-of-year audit opinion um which
will be presented to to your sales at
year end
thank you thank you
um emily did you want to come in before
i move to
coachella mclaren please yes thank you
chairman i just wanted to um really add
um some weight to john's answer to
councillor matheson's question
and just provide the committee with some
reassurance that we
absolutely have taken a balanced
and um evidence decision to
um to use an external supplier for our
internal audit provision
and so it's not just a case of being
unable to recruit we've actually looked
at it across the board
and the use of the external provider
actually gives us
lots of benefits in terms of the wider
pool of skills that we now have access
to we're able to draw on really kind of
specialist
audit areas that you actually wouldn't
get in an in-house team because you
couldn't maintain
that level of skill across a broad
spectrum of
of disciplines so actually counselors i
think we really have the best of both
worlds and we have
some in-house members of the team who we
can quickly redeploy to different tasks
to support the corporate business of the
organization
but we also have this uh really kind of
diverse and skilled partner that we can
use
for all different types of audits and
actually as john said
they were able to support some of that
covid work and the new
um kind of business that we've had come
on stream because of our response to
covid so
i just really wanted to provide that
reassurance that it's not kind of an
accidental
situation we have um deliberately used
this
external provider and they do provide us
with with some real benefits
thank you chairman thank you emily uh
councilman mclaren please
thank you chair john uh first of all i
just want to thank you
for such a comprehensive report and all
the information is
quite clear as it's set out um
considering the pressures that your
department are under
um about the grant funding i think
that's been dealt with i
i wasn't um i was wondering if
at some point you might publish the
the results of fraudulent claims
i don't know whether that's possible or
not but i should imagine it's early days
in terms of grants and things that have
been
uh applied for uh sorry counselor i
think you just
cut out slightly there that's the
critical point um
was it you were looking for for for the
numbers of different types of guaranteed
payments
at some point will you be publishing the
perhaps the level of fraudulent claims
around
grant applications yes cancer that will
come out in the year report
managing the risk of fraud and
corruption i'm pleased
to say um
at this stage we've had very few
fraudulent
claims uh we've picked up a couple one
was at the application stage and one was
at uh after a payment had been made and
we are actually recruit
clawing that back um so
but the emphasis the government's
emphasis at the time was
to get those payments out as quickly as
possible and then do the post checks
in an ideal world had we had the time we
were done a lot more pre-checks than
post checks
um but we are now almost placing catch
up that's not just with babe remove
suffolk that again
that's right across the land um and
again and we're working with
ipswich as well which is borough council
who have been very supportive
in the work that we've been doing so
thus far and we're also using the
government spotlight which
is almost like a data matching type
approach um
where we can highlight potential
fraudulent claims of
being that have come our way but at the
moment it's very low
uh i'm pleased to say and obviously we
wish that to be the case as we move
forward
just one final question john um
procurement i noticed in your report
uh it's a a topic that i'm quite
interested in
um i saw in your report that you
reported that there's been
some progress i think in in what you do
in you know what they're doing but are
we on track
with procurement to achieve a better
sort of rigor within that system
yeah yes certainly councillor um the
reason
why we've had to defer that audit and i
have i have had discussions with melissa
who is unfortunately not here but
um i don't know if you can recall
that the east of england earlier lga
did a piece of work on our behalf which
started right about christmas time
obviously got delayed through obviously
the initial covet uh
position and i understand and i'm sure
catherine may correct me if i'm wrong
but we have now received a draft report
which i think we received on the 6th of
october from
them that is let's say is that draft
stage that will need to be ratified at
some point by
by management and i would imagine an
action plan developed from that
so i agreed with uh melissa that it
wouldn't
it wouldn't benefit the organization at
this stage to go in there and
basically do an audit which wouldn't add
any value at all and only perhaps
reproduce
some of the findings that um that the
east of england lga produced
so on that agreement that we're going to
push that back to next year
and then carry on there but hopefully a
roll out of an action plan and obviously
there'll be time from embedment as well
but we will pick that up next year for
you uh if that gives you the assurance
you're looking for
counsellor thank you john thank you
chair
thank you casey mccarron occasionally
the crawl please
thank you chair uh i'd just like to ask
john
the uh in appendix b on page 67
uh paratu
internal audit reports with adverse
opinions
i note you've just identified one uh
audit opinion of limited assurance would
that be the housing matter you referred
to earlier
yes that's correct counselor all right
so you've covered that already then
i'd just like to ask there were some
areas um where we
if you returned an audit opinion of
limited assurance in the last financial
year
i wonder if you could very briefly run
through those areas
and how they've been addressed obviously
they are from last year so they're
historical
um and and and why perhaps do you think
that they
uh don't require a declaration of
limited assurance now
okay
the first one is the it purchasing it's
uh two one two one one and then below
that
okay
you just bear with me a second i'll just
open that up got some documents over
there
since they were identified last year i
thought it would be useful to know
uh that they you know there's that we've
only got one now but they were i think
we were three then
yes so with the the first one uh
which is uh 2.1.1 which was
the it purchasing um so
in terms of the present status we've
obviously done
where we've given a live insurance we
then provide sort of follow-up work as
you quite rightly say counselor
and so the present status there is uh
we've had discussions
with matt harding who's the corporate
manager for it
and those obviously areas where we felt
that there was some concern
at the time of his predecessor
these have now been put right and
there's certainly a far more robust
process in place for managing um
sort of items of large software
purchases
contracts proof of purchase etc
and again in terms of the infantry items
again
matt's got a real handle in terms of
who's got what
as you can imagine at the moment
particularly with kovid working from
home we were
we needed to have a clear record of
what equipment was owned by who and
obviously those serial numbers are now
sort of matched up to to individual
offices etc
so in terms of that um more than happy
with um the processes now that matt's
got in place
and feel comfortable with with that
arrangement um
so is that is that um
yeah so please please uh interrupt
counselor if uh
that's fine i just just it was really
just because it had been identified it
was the progress from year to year
and then you've got the workplace
security and contract management which i
think of course
has been referred to in part by council
mclaren
yeah and absolutely um because of some
of the findings
uh we've obviously now provided a lot
more advice and guidance on general
security measures
um to staff across
the council through through the working
together newsletter
so that's far more and robust if you
like but obviously we're now working
from home
largely so a lot of that
isn't necessarily a concern at this
stage but obviously
we've spoken to
continue with your question please
yes i'm not sure where we we we stopped
um somewhere
oh sorry chair this is better
um yes i was talking about asset
community value did we
you you that was the first question with
that john
respond briefly on that one yeah you did
yeah
thank you chair thank you uh councillor
but yeah i'll take on board
um your comments particularly around
about the appeals process
uh and the levels of engagement um
across all parties so thank you yeah
i'm not not quite i'm not clear whether
we are unable to have
the engagement that seem to be lacking
um
and you know under whose control that is
whether it's
external to us or whatever i don't know
but it
it didn't it wasn't any good um
secondly on the was the disabled
facility grants where
um you know with the the experience
is seems to be that the um the delays
um in getting getting assessments done
this is uh
occupational therapy what's it called
yeah occupational
therapy um expertise
um you know the the the result it's just
not meeting the needs
that are that are out there um
and that's that's that's a concern and
um thirdly a bit further down the page
the holding company um
wherever that one is on page 64. um
yeah i i know that the
it actually took us three years to start
work on
housing on the need and market hq um
site or the car park site actually um
which which and i think we need to
uh sharpen up considerably there in
terms of
you know there's a loss of opportunity
if you like um
well and money um on on that one so
there's
three points there that perhaps need
looking at thank you chair
thank you thank you thank you very much
um do we have any more questions
i i have a couple john very brief ones
actually john
paragraph 2.1.1 it's actually on the top
of page 68
which is item 4 under the present status
this is relating to the it purchasing uh
internal audit opinion limited assurance
we say here that we are reviewing assets
not mentioned above for example tablets
with a view to understanding numbers
ownership and financial
impact do you actually have a date have
you given sort of colleagues um
officers a date when you actually want
that information by
uh thank you chair um actually that's
something that i'm uh
sort of liaising with with matt harding
who's responsible for that so
i don't have a date but that's something
obviously i can pick up with him
directly
thank you very much the other comment i
had was was in relation to item 6.1.1
health of the organization
under payroll again we've got draft
report with management for response
but there's no date to when the response
is required
um have managers been asked a specific
day to provide you with this information
please john
yes yes they have and it's something
that i need to take on board it's been
raised before where i think it'd be
useful to have
a date so it's clear for members when
they are expecting or when i should be
respecting a response so
um that actually response is i think
we've actually just received it so
we'll be able to finalize that report
but i think it will be useful for you
councillors as
in terms of how i report that i actually
give you uh a date
uh for completion so that that point
taken on board so thank you
thank you john uh councillor matheson
did you want to come back yes thank you
yes i don't want to labor labour this
point because i can see that we've got a
few items still on the agenda
but the i did have a look at the um
in terms of auditing our um strategic
policies um strategic environmental
policies
that the um that when when
opportunity you know is there and we're
a little bit
um further out of the crisis
of covid um that we've got appropriate
performance standards
and indicators and um that procurement
is
um is is serving the environmental
policy
through through um you know local
purchasing and that kind of thing
i also noticed a reference to the local
development framework
um which is is i think now an
out-of-date term
that's in the actual statement of um
strategic policies and um
and finally that the that work would
need to
be updated in line with the work of the
recommendations the task and finish
panel on on our environmental strategy
yeah thank you councillor um if i can
just respond briefly we had actually
planned to do some work around the
climate change
and the action plan that fell out from
from that group
i've spoken to cassandra clements and
because obviously covet et cetera
things have been pushed back and what
i'd had hoped to achieve this year but
it will be pushed back to next year
um as this significant piece of work um
is actually to do a health check
against that action plan and then
obviously report back to this committee
thank you thank you very much do we have
any more questions
please none at all thank you i know
moving to debate
does anybody wish to debate this this um
item at all
no no i just have one it's sort of part
question and part comment really john on
this one
i was particularly interested in i'm
going back to item 2.1.2 the workplace
security
present status advice and guidance on
general security measures have been
communicated to staff
in the council's working together news
newsletter i was just really curious on
this this particular
answer are our managers satisfied that
their staff are actually reading this
very very important piece of information
because we read so much these days about
security and id security and various
things i've certainly read articles
about in the witch magazine and various
other
newspapers and that so from your
knowledge are our managers aware
that their staff have actually read read
this important piece of information
and then they confirm that they have i
can't
um provide that level of assurance
perhaps you're looking for
obviously the working deal newsletters
they do come out
yeah the expectation is for um
to ensure each manager ensures that
their staff have have read that and if
there are
very important issues uh within those
newsletters
then again that should be coming out
within their team meetings perhaps they
want
ones to to reinforce those key messages
to staff
um so that would be my expectation
obviously it'd be lovely for me to
touch base with all my corporate
managers
but my sense is yes they do
i think it's heightened in the sense
that obviously with kobit 19
we are reading far more um and there's
some really focused messages
and again um my expectation would be for
managers to
to have that conversation with their
staff and also a two-way
conversation if you like for staff to
then raise issues concerns that they
have uh upwards to to their managers as
well
yeah yeah thank you for that john the
only the only actual reason i raised
that because
in my past life as a manager in the
civil service
i if we got something really important
or important piece of legislation
that um you know staff ought to read i
would then circulate to my junior
managers who in turn would circulate to
their admin staff
and they would you know tick that or
sign their name on in a folder i
appreciate you can't do that with covert
at the moment
but that particular thing stuck out with
me is basically how important that issue
is but you know i'm satisfied with your
response
thank you for that john emily did you
wish to come in briefly on that please
yeah thank you chairman i just also
wanted to mention the online gdpr
training that all
staff are required to do and we're
actually just now
going through the refresh of that
training so it's two years since
it originally was done by all staff
we're refreshing that now and there is a
specific module in there around cyber
security
and a real emphasis on not just
understanding data protection rights but
also
general i.t and workplace security as
well
so i just wanted to mention that chair
thank you very much mma thank you
um councillor mccraw did you wish to
join the debate
just to comment in many cases from
experience i'd expect
most managers to already communicated
the contents
of the newsletter before it's even
printed particularly if it's of
relevance to their own department i mean
it's just a matter of
the day-to-day conversation that would
be the normal thing to do i would have
thought
yeah i do agree with you uh councilman
crawl if there are no more sort of
issues for the debate um i'd like to
thank john very much for his very
detailed report superb report
that report is actually just for noting
so again thank you very much john for
all your
your work on that i'd like to move on to
agenda item number 10
which is jack 20 stroke 5 the progress
update
on the committee on standards in public
life practice recommendations and could
i invite emily please
to present the report thank you emily
thank you chairman i'd like to present
report number jac25 which seeks the
committee's approval
of the attached progress report um to
the committee on standards in public
life
on its 15 best practice recommendations
the joint audit and standards committee
received an initial self-assessment on
these recommendations
in july 2019 but the committee on
standards in public life has now
formally
requested a written progress update on
the implementation of these
recommendations
predominantly the councils have already
got processes in place which support the
recommendations
or are able to meet them with a few
minor minor amendments
however there are three recommendations
that i am proposing that the councils do
not
adopt as detailed in the report and i'd
just like to remind the committee that
these are just best practice
recommendations
so we are not obligated to adopt them
the report also seeks the committee's
endorsement of a revised code of conduct
complaints procedure
this procedure will support the
implementation of the best practice
recommendations
and draws together various process
documents that we use when dealing with
code of conduct complaints
ultimately this will make the process
clearer for complainants
and counsellors who are the subject of
the complaint
i'm happy to take any questions chairman
thank you very much does anybody have
any questions for
emily please on her paper counselor
mccraw
it's just a question i have a paper
marked jac 20 stroke
6 on modern.moderngov
we've referred twice to jac20 stroke
five
has there been a revision as as far as
i'm aware chair
there are um two separate papers there's
jack 25 which is
the update on the public life practice
recommendations
and jack 26 is item 11 which is a code
of conduct complaints monitoring report
i apologize chair okay thank you
do we have any questions at all for for
emily
does anyone else wish should oh
counselor mclaren please
thank you chair thank you emily um
in these standards of course parish
councils
are involved and they're a sort of group
of people over which
um we have less uh supervision and
control
um what would you see as
the training programme for paris because
paris councillors are changing all the
time
um would you see any programme of
training being put in place for parish
councils
thank you chairman and thank you council
mclaren for that question
um so alongside these best practice
recommendations we've also got the
committee on standards in public life's
recommendations around the new model
code of conduct
um which will imminently be published
and we're expecting that in the early
part of
december to be agreed by the local
government association
um so with that new model code of
conduct what i'm expecting is that we
will again
seek to have a county-wide code of local
code of conduct
and so we will make and agree any
revisions as a as a county-wide group
and that will incorporate town and
parish councils
in both districts um and then i would
suggest and i would be recommending to
colleagues across suffolk that we do a
kind of shared um training training
package
um that complements that new model code
of conduct um and that would be
delivered
um in collaboration with the suffolk
association of local councils
um so there would be kind of a and the
use of the opportunity of a new local
code or an
updated local code to roll out a
training program and then we would look
to support parish councils as they have
new
councillors at any point in the year um
we do
also um on occasion go out to individual
town and parish councils where there's a
particular training need so if they've
had
a high turnover of councillors or if
there are some issues within that town
or parish council
would go out and do a bespoke training
session for them
thank you because it's um what i was
going to say
is that as councillors district
councillors
um we often can be great
encouragers if you like i mean i i want
to encourage my parish councils
to participate in anything that is
makes their um job and their
activity more professional if you like
thank you thank you emily thank you
chair thank you very much council
mclaren thank you emily for that
question
if there are no more questions or no
members wish to debate this
issue i'd like to move on to the
recommendations which are found in
paragraphs 2.1 and 2.2 in the report on
page 77.
could i ask for a proposal please and a
seconder
cashler mclaren you wish to propose i do
wish to propose
and coach councillor caston yeah thank
you very much mr chairman wished to
second that
thank you very much indeed um can i ask
there we now have a proposal a second
here
can we can i ask the governor's office
to go to the vote please thank you
thank you chair um councillors could you
please open the vote in modern.gov app
um by clicking uh clicking on the plus
sign in the top right of the agenda
screen
and selecting attendance and voting in
the voting tab
yeah the vote for this agenda will show
in blue you may need to scroll down
and please click on the blue line to
open the vote
so
thank you chair that's unanimously for
thank you very much indeed mandy thank
you
i now like to move on to agenda item 11
jack 20 stroke
6 and i'd again like to invite emily to
talk about um the report from the
monitoring officer
thank you thank you chairman i'd like to
present
the report which is the code of conduct
complaints monitoring report
this is purely a statistical report to
provide information to the committee on
the number of complaints received and
the outcome of those complaints
the committee will note that there
continues to be a high number of
complaints received
particularly in the baba district the
majority of which however relate to town
and parish councils
we are also experiencing a high volume
of informal inquiries
and requests for procedural advice from
town and parish councils
i'm very happy to take any questions
chairman but i may be limited on how
much information i can give on a
particular complaint
subject to the status of that complaint
thank you thank you emily
thank you do any members have any
questions counselor caston please
thank you very much oh sorry my camera's
down a bit though
um so this kind of covers both of these
um
these reports um i just wondered what
is there ever a complaint made we've
we've got the
initial um look at
a complaint when it comes in um by the
monitoring officer to
and and we had some details of when
complaints won't be upheld
and um is it always the case that the
district councillor
is informed when a complaint
is against him or her um just for
sort of ongoing behavior issues
um you know just to just to make sure
that
whatever that complaint was even if it
was initially thrown out
um the the counselor could um manage
that
situation
yeah thank you for your your question um
so when the complaint goes through
initial assessment um we tend to make a
judgment call
on the merits of informing the counselor
about that complaint
so if it's a complaint that's completely
outside the code of conduct and
maybe for example it's a complaint about
the whole parish council rather than an
individual counsellor
we wouldn't necessarily inform that
individual counsellor because it's not
captured by the code of conduct
where it's a trivial or vexatious
complaint
which would be dismissed we would maybe
um inform the counselor who's the
subject of the complaint on that
occasion
um so it it really depends on the nature
of the complaint
the reason it's being dismissed and
perhaps any ongoing issues because in
some cases
um if there's a kind of ongoing dispute
it might not be
um beneficial for us to inform the
councillor about a kind of um
low-level complaint or something that's
not met the threshold of the code of
conduct
um so it is a case-by-case um judgment
but we do tend to inform
counsellors um because actually the
complainant will
will quite often publicly state that
they've made a code of conduct complaint
in any case so we do want to keep people
informed
and and as you've alluded to counselor
casting we do look out for any
patterns of behavior so perhaps
something that doesn't breach the code
of conduct but demonstrates
um perhaps a lack of understanding
around a particular issue we kind of
want to spot that and raise that with
the counsellor in an
informal way
thank you thank you very much um
councillor lindsay please
thank you chair um just wondered if um
is there a how concentrated are
[Music]
are these complaints concentrated around
a
one or two particular as it were
troublesome parishes
um or is it because i noticed there's a
big difference
just between baby and mid suffolk so it
may just be
one or two parish councils that are
skewing their figures as it were
is that am i along the right lines
yes councillors so um for this reports
monitoring period
um this complaints monitoring period
there are two particular parish councils
um where the majority of the the
complaints sit
um so they do they do tend to come in
clusters because
um quite often an event will occur and
several people will complain about that
single
occasion so um they they are slightly
skewed by um
two particular hot spots if you like
thank you thank you very much council
lindsay do we have any more questions
for
emily please counselor caston please
um yeah following on from councillor
lindsay's um
question would it be useful to um
split that again into parish councils
because obviously if there's
if there's eight mem parish councillors
on a parish council on the complaints
about all of them
it's very different to eight different
parish councils having eight different
complaints
um from my point of view i i just
wondered if that would be a useful way
of
laying that out
chairman i'm more than happy to to look
at alternative ways of displaying the
the statistics and perhaps to give a
clear into indication to
um the committee about the spread of
complaints
um and and maybe even to say um
where their complaints about um separate
counsellors or individual counselors
with repeat complaints obviously not
naming any particular counsellor but
just to also give you
that kind of demonstration of um where
we do have
um several complaints about a single
issue
thank you very much emily thank you
councillor mccraw
on that point emily and
james i just and this is a question
going to follow
i just point out that identifying
individual councils
uh could also be problematic um since um
identification of a an individual uh
would be relatively straightforward um
so it might be careful we might be
careful to
draw that attention to that matter
particularly in the
matter of vexatious complaints uh
i would just look well i'm so pointing
this out but i'm just asking emily if
i'm correct in thinking this
uh i noticed the time scales for
the reports um are different time
periods one is about six months
and one would be about ten months
so uh i see when i be right thinking a
seeming increase it might not be
just that proportionately per month it's
not
terribly different no the the
um report obviously presentationally
does um
look higher because it is a longer
reporting period
um however you can see from sort of the
middle of last year
we are seeing this higher level of
complaints being received
um ideally this report would come to the
committee on a quarterly basis
um so you would have a shorter reporting
period
but just because of various issues with
the scheduling of this committee
and um kind of more more urgent business
to be transacted
there's just been a longer period of
time for this report to come through on
this occasion
i have some thoughts on why that might
be but i'll bring leave that for debate
yeah
thank you very much emily if there are
no more questions i'd like to move
straight into debate
and alison mccraw did you counsel mccraw
do you wish to sort of raise the issues
now
as we know in debate this is purely
observational
chair um but i have noted that uh
the kovid 19 lockdown has seen an awful
lot of people
uh not going to work and staying at home
um
and perhaps our communities contain
people
people have also been getting their
exercise quite noticeably our footpath
use seems to have
climbed dramatically and because of that
people may be more aware of local issues
in their communities
and being aware and having time on their
hands
are perhaps more inclined to raise
questions
that otherwise would not have been
raised and i think that could be a
contributing factor
to the increase that we may be seeing
thank you councilman
councillor haran please yes thank you
chair
i think it might just be helpful on the
paper to
state somewhere that um the
councillors be they parish or district
have been notified that there is a
complaint against them because um
look at that paper um there's been six
and then nine complaints against
councillors that's 15. they could all
have been against me couldn't they
um not that i would ever be that bad but
i think
it frightens us all unnecessarily
um to think there have been that many
complaints we don't need to know who
they are but i think
some sort of note that the um uh
counselors
who have been complained about have been
just made aware i think it would be
helpful to the rest of us that's just a
a point chairman thank you
counselor just to add in chair that it's
important to note how few uh complaints
have been upheld
and had any action taken i think that
should be drawn you know attention
should be drawn to that
thank you very much for that comment uh
council mccraw do we have any other sort
of comments of the debate at all
no well that report is just for noting
so thank you very much emily
for both of your reports that's much
appreciated
our final report today is uh jack 20
stroke 8
which is the joint audit standards
committee forward plan
this is on page 125 to 128.
do members have any comments or
amendments they would like to make to
that plan at all
just have a moment to get up to catch up
with that one chair
no problem
casually macro all i was going to say
chair is it seems to me very much like
repeat and rinse um the pattern
of our meetings does follow a certain
routine and
that we'll be looking at many of the
matters we've looked at at this meeting
and at last meeting which is what you'd
expect yeah
thank you councillor mccraw casey
matheson did you did you wish to make a
comment at all
yeah i i think um yeah i think the point
about
um repeat etc um it's
it's good to see this laid out because
of course we haven't
um we we haven't sustained
um the pattern of two monthly meetings
through this year
like we we've discussed and we know why
why that was
and um i think i just feel a general
sense that the
um the turbulence for the financial
turbulence
that we've we've talked about earlier in
the meeting
um i i felt as if perhaps
i needed to know more
and more quickly if we were running into
serious troubles and
in fact many many councils have been
running into great
a lot of trouble uh and it's been
reassuring
during the morning to hear that we we
basically haven't
um so um yes i think that's just a
general observation it's good to see
that pattern laid out
and um you know it'll be good to hear
that some of the new and different
aspects of all
of internal audit are um
are coming along um so
yes that's that's fine i'll i'll propose
it if you'd like
it's just for noting actually thank you
so that's fine
so if we've got no more questions or any
any sort of items for debate
um i will then conclude the meeting at
11 44.
the next meeting is currently scheduled
for the 25th of january 2021
at 9 30. i'd like to pass on my thanks
to the officers
for all their reports and also to
members for their very constructive
comments
uh etc during today's meeting so thank
you very much so i
formally closed the meeting but if
you